oh my god it's him
it looks like him
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen it is now time to
watch the book of boba fett chapter six
don't know what the title of this
episode is yet because that's how d-plus
rolls
guys
use the force
to hit the like button subscribe and
click that notification bell
if you were really satisfied with that
last episode and you want to check out
our reaction for the next one
also check this out full length watch
alongs where you sync up with the time
code they're over at our patreon page
massive thanks to all of become
superjects but check out all the content
that we got to offer blind wave recently
moved all their content over to our
patreon page thank you guys it's really
giving us a good boost
boys at prepper
thank you guys for helping us down these
highlights
this is the way
this is the way
this is live
[Music]
we'll leave the spice and take the
credits back to mozambique the rest will
follow do you know where you are
gentlemen oh
god
dig it through
hell yeah load up your wares and head
back to where you came we can chalk this
one up to you guys reading the map wrong
bowls
cobb shot first
[Music]
sexy cowboy and every one of those pikes
was a celebrity cameo
[Music]
come on let's get high
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so excited
go visit some jedi
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
we going to the places
that we are my friend
[Music]
what if we see ben solo
oh
dude that'd be cool
tie it all together
buddy
[ __ ] oh
that's shaboosh technology
eat it
[Music]
oh
buddy i love his little try face
that has really improved yeah what's
changed
[Music]
why have one frog when you can have many
you will never want for frogs again
all right let's go for a walk
chamook who was the guy who was hired
the deep fake guy
yeah
i want to tell you about someone you
remind me of a great deal
and my time in dagobah his name was yoda
[Music]
he was small like you
he would speak in riddles
improper english
do you remember back home
would you like to remember
holy [ __ ]
be okay buddy
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
it's cool to see them in practical suits
yeah
[Music]
i will teach you to protect yourself
this really is the mandalorian season
three
seriously we'll get back to all that
stuff later we don't need to we know
what you guys want
[Music]
to expect to see you here
neither did i
i'm an old friend of the family i
thought you weren't going to help train
kroger
i'm not master lucas that's cool she
gets to interact with luke
what is this place there's nothing now
that will someday be a great school
yeah you should have the greatest
first student
oh he's the first okay i don't
understand why you're all right with
skywalker's decision to train the kid
when you wouldn't because it was his
choice i don't control the wants of
others then it's my choice to go and see
him hmm
of course
if that is what you wish
croco
[Music]
i want to give him this
why
so he will remember you
no
there's a mandalorian
foundling he should have this it's his
right
i'm getting emotional under there this
armor will protect him
it's like a mithril thing mm-hmm yeah
little chain mail probably
rogan misses you a great deal
if he sees you it will only make things
more difficult for him
oh god damn it right now we're soaking
right here
make sure he's protected
oh
man dude you're the best dad
[Music]
oh
buddy
oh
man
[Music]
scared him like yoda
[ __ ] that goddamn
freaking show
bend down
jump and as you do
feel the force flow through you
oh my god
you're trying too hard
don't try
come on i want to show you something
my guys are zipping around like superman
hey
that's great
[Music]
[Laughter]
now go raise another x-wing at the swamp
that's it
very good
it's just great puppeteering too
is grogu about to wheel the lightsaber
yes do it
[Music]
oh awesome
this is a training remote
it will test your reflexes
[Music]
there you go you did the jump very good
oh my god
oh my god luke and ahsoka interacting
with each other
[Music]
you guys interact with each other
say something oh my gosh gonna break it
oh
good
now fix it we only have one of those
it's more like he's remembering that i'm
actually teaching him anything
[Music]
sometimes the student guides the master
nice you brought him a gift
sometimes i wonder if this heart is in
it so much like your father
crazy
crazy
what should i do about him
trust your instincts that will always go
well
[Music]
right but what do you want
what's wrong with you
just tell me what you want right
are you acting out you're acting now
give me a mission kill some people okay
[Laughter]
this is the mandalorian dinjarin
thanks to him and chris anton we now
have enough experienced muscle to act as
enforcers
we lack the numbers to cover our
territory if an all-out war comes
we need foot soldiers i might be able to
help with that
call up your boy cobb i like how that
was their reunion
you want to park your starship you got
to do it out there in the flat i'm
looking for marshall vance
i don't think you heard what i said
i heard you i'll take it from here
deputy
oh you just came out of nowhere
hiding behind him this whole thing
we need good people to step up or the
spice is bound to come through these
parts as long as i'm here that's not a
problem i fought side by side with the
citizens of freetown and they're brave
people and the pike syndicate has us
outnumbered and we need your help things
are tough around here but i'll see what
i can do
get the word out i want all men and
women of fighting age to come to town i
won't have a meeting
it's not our problem marshall no but it
might be after they hear what i'm going
to say
you already got pikes coming through
this territory
is that cat bait
that's just the next best cabin
she gets your list down
tell these people to head inside for a
spill
something wrong marshall i hope not i've
already sold myself
holy [ __ ]
looks like him where's that blue face
no he would kill cobb oh don't no don't
kill cobb though the pike set him oh my
god it's him
action campaign
[Music]
and all you've got to do is stay put and
let things play out don't bully cobb hey
the marshall ain't for sale dude you're
gonna get yourself dude
you're gonna get yourself killed
[Music]
i can't believe this is happening
boba
a cold-blooded killer who worked for the
empire
oh crap they got a history
you should have never given up your
armor
no please please god
no
no no
do not want
kill that guy cat
yeah warning shot
oh definitely
oh
as long as the spice keeps running
everyone will be left alone
[Music]
please
please back to tank
it's up to you now barkeep i i can't
believe we got a live action cabin we
might actually see the flashback of the
no maybe we wouldn't
i'll say that talk after
slay it all day
after you rise it up
and all your next episode cameo wishes
out
are they like gigolos too
it really does
yeah just like
concubines i feel like american horror
story vibes from this
[Laughter]
oh
no
grogu beat ben solo
you guys are going to be bunk mates
the mandalorian wanted you to have this
looks a little small i mean he will
eventually grow out of it before you
take it i will give you a choice
this is the blue pill
oh my god damn
why are you doing this tim is a
lightsaber
it belonged to my teacher master yoda
i'm offering it to you
i'm just gonna put this one a little
closer
if you choose the armor you'll return to
your friend the mandalorian
but if you choose the lightsaber you
will be the first student in my academy
and i will train you to be a great jedi
sophie's choice
and you may never see the mandalorian
again because grogu a short time for you
is a lifetime for someone else
[Music]
season three is in your hands child
no
come on
felony mum now in the direction too
oh they originally had him and uh
they're gonna like the the ropes that i
assume in like last journey stuff i
can't believe boba put this all in his
book
willing to share the start
that's great but there are a whole lot
of other main characters i gotta say
what i was saying was that there's um
there's uh some they didn't actually get
a
fully bring it to life with cab bait and
boba when they square it off and that's
how he has like a hole in his head or
something
and so i was wondering if i see a
flashback of that i mean the future's
wide open for something like that now
it's crazy now he looks like something
out of american horse yes
like a menacing alien i love it i mean
the first guy of the default the dark
saber was both he had both let him be
both
come on man
maybe you should uh play in the gray a
little bit
do a little gray jedi action
man a second ass silhouette showed up in
that kung fu western yeah
david carradine like talking
i did not see that coming at all
like in that moment especially
uh and i hope i hope somehow cobb vance
is not dead
yes we thought like like they didn't
explain how did bad badge ever explain
how he he just lived because he was
presumed dead for a while but then he
came back in bad batch but
what a presence yeah a presence in just
a couple of minutes yeah
it was a great standoff too just like
all that tension
easily the best part was when they check
in with bob
oh dude and the mods are back thank
goodness
to boba even speak then
i think fennek did all the talking
that's good wow
wow
that was the episode right there at some
point he's going to be wearing that me
throwing ortix gonna stab him yeah
that's right
boom these last two episodes man that is
so much star wars all they needed was to
make it the mandalorian
ladies gentlemen i uh
not gonna be able to talk clearly yeah
that is that was overwhelming
would have had a conflict of emotions at
the same time like just the fan service
through the roof while moving like
moving the freaking storyline goddamn
speed force
and um
and then creating just like the
conflicts of choices
it's it's like freaking like when cat
bane shows up it's like holy [ __ ] we got
a cat baby here
and
and uh like there's such a history with
him actually i think if i'm not mistaken
he was one of the people who did mentor
boba early on in the days of bounty
hunting if i'm not mistaken
so there's such a rich history between
them and the last time they saw each
other was via a duel
so you know like there is there's a lot
to mind there and then the second i'm
like oh crap no he might kill cobb damn
this is not what i wanted
yeah yeah you were so happy to see this
guy and now he's about to break your
heart yeah and uh because that's yeah
campaign's uh he's an antagonist and to
to introduce like that is crazy and it's
what's cool about how they handled it
here i thought was obviously for people
who have like you know seen clone wars
or a very minimum bad match
you'll have familiarity with who the
character is but regardless of that the
way
filoni and crew framed him here
had such a villainous presence the
entire time and he is like menacing and
scary to behold to do anything and i'm
glad they put him in like practical
makeup because yeah that was
uncomfortable to look at it and i loved
it i just loved the way he looked
and it just feels like plucked out of
there i thought i'd be a little bluer
but
he still feels like he's all blue but i
thought he'd be even like bluer yeah
but he still looks so great and it's
it's just awesome to look at but that
conflict of choice and then
of course to see like the early days of
luke being like ain't nothing bad gonna
happen here today dude
best school known
i'm gonna train all the best jedi it's
gonna be awesome
um yeah it makes you do wonder what the
future of groku might be you know like
they as they established with um
the original person to wield the
darksaber that was mandalorian and jedi
and now uh
now he's giving him a choice and that is
so conflicting you know and
i
would
reckon that he would go down the path of
mandalorian ultimately
because
this is our first time hearing of grogu
he's not talked about at all i mean
unless there's just some unfortunate
fate where
ben solo did kill him you know
or met he maybe left the school before
any of that happened
at this same time like well you know
disney wants to make their money and you
want to keep you want to keep baby yoda
on the show with the jordan right yeah
absolutely and it wouldn't be practical
just to always kind of side quest out to
school to go pop in and make sure he's
okay yeah get redundant after a while
yeah and then to finally see like ahsoka
and luke interact with each other the
paddle one of anak and skywalker coming
all the way full circle here where they
get to interact with each other like
there's no one other than you know
obi-wan there's no one else who could
say of your your lot like your father in
a positive endearing way
more so than ahsoka tano can say
and like to get those scenes and then
all the freaking like callbacks and
references and then also still moving
the story forward with training grogu
when you're like there's so much empire
strikes back happening right
yeah except it's not like some you know
foggy sway nice
it's beautiful to look at and you're
watching him advance and
grow and grow growing grogu
uh yeah i i was uh i was very
overwhelmed and then the jarring was
like bringing me to tears like he's
wanted nothing like clearly misses
grosgu so much and he just
can't say it and he's just trying to do
what's best for him and he travels all
this way
literally travels the galaxy yeah
he just outrans space cops to get here
and he waited forever for someone to
greet him to guide him to there and then
when he's right there to see him he
doesn't even
he doesn't even get a chance to say
anything to him you know
um
oh that was that was heartbreaking that
could freaking kill i mean it looks like
they killed off cobb
it looks like it i feel like because
they lit up his deputy way more and he
got shot in the once i'm hoping that
something happens or next episode it's
revealed that he's all right uh but i
could actually i could see them you know
making cadbane just murk him in cold
blood and give us that much more reason
to hate this guy i think the
implementation of the history that cabin
brings via boba fett
would really allow us to see or maybe
have some type of scene hopefully
um
i really say hopefully because clearly
the last two episodes have been like the
best it shows me
um
would really allow us to
hone in a little bit more on boba's
character change you know more so than a
time spent with the tuscan raiders
really allowing us to
understand perhaps more in depth was
he's like saying pope is a cold-blooded
killer and of course the last time cad
bane was hanging out with bobo yeah
that's the version he remembers and
to
to have him like warn combat about that
but also the death of khadvan but also
cause all the people who were taking
more of a pacifistic method towards this
fight might actually rally together to
help fight
and that bartender is going to become
the new sheriff of freetown yeah
but yeah this was like an interesting
episode because
like mandalorian feels expansive to a
degree but it also feels like it's its
own kind of niche of the star wars
galaxy to me
and then you have this boba fett show
which in some ways has felt like even
more of a niche and this episode sure
yeah and this episode really
like the appearance of a character like
cad bane even more so in some degrees
than luke just because we've already
seen him here and we've already seen
ahsoka on this program it's like
something about this episode and that
especially made it feel that much more
expansive consequential to the greater
picture of things well i felt like we
were watching a star wars movie exactly
where the last one felt like
mandalorian season three episode one
this was cutting around to so many
different story lines like a star wars
movie it felt like yeah yeah just like a
star wars story and not the book of boba
fett not the mandalorians just were in
all different walks of the star wars
world and all of them are interlocking
to some degree and
like 10 seconds of boba fett and 10
seconds
i'm fascinated as to how and why the
show came together quite the way it did
because for the first four episodes it
makes absolute sense and now
i'm like it's the book of boba fett with
a couple issues of a couple other books
slipped in and then it'll kind of come
back to boba fett i imagine by the end
of it but cause even when it cuts back
to boba i'm like
apparently this is the least interesting
barely seems concerned with him yeah
yeah absolutely and and you know i i
felt that too and that's coming from
somebody who's enjoyed most all the boba
stuff up to this point to some degree i
have i've really enjoyed episodes two
and four a lot
and then here but these last two are
just on another level yeah
yeah and um
i just feel so much more pertinent for
some reason yeah yeah
and uh he's more emotional and just so
much more connected and it feels more
star wars
and uh the way
the way things progress with the pikes
too you know they actually brought them
to a point that felt menacing that felt
really threatening they blow up that one
freaking bar we keep going back to on
tattoo
you know yep straight up blow it to
smithereens yeah man the pike's higher
freaking the syndicate hires goddamn cat
bane poor garcia whipped
i mean i thought uh
oh my god what is her name amelia clark
here
oh kira kira yeah my god i thought she
might show up um still good
uh yeah seeing the way this [ __ ] is
going real crazy
[Music]
man what harrison ford shows up what if
maybe i mean we got to talk about that
luke skywalker deep fake a little bit
because like they hired shamook i
remember i think it was him who they
hired who did like amazing he does
amazing deep fakes on youtube
and so and i think one of his biggest
ones was like
here's what mandalorian did with luke
here's what i did with the deep fake and
it looks so much better
and uh
and there are times where it just looked
like like wow this is uncanny like this
is like so crazy yeah like this looks
like so flawless uh and there are times
where it still look like oh this is kind
of weird
i can really see that chin shadow you
can see you can really see like that's
not mark hamill performing and they're
trying to match the voiceover
yeah there's a lot of dubbing here yeah
he has to keep i thought they split the
difference because when he shows up in
mandalorian for the second season he's
very stoic and i thought they did hear
a better job with he's still kind of
straight and a little when i say flat i
mean in the way that star wars dialogue
delivery can be flowers part of the
aesthetic i mean he he delivers every
line the same way pretty much yes
exactly yeah
yeah but it it was like yeah while there
are seams it was like wow they have
really advanced this effect and it looks
like bottom line it looks way better
than before while it's not perfect for
for a minute there i thought like they
perfected this it's not yeah
but i don't think this will spurn as
many like i did it myself and it's way
better on the internet no and the story
is so essential to be told and they are
filling in a very important gap in star
wars lore
from what happened between return of the
jedi to the force awakens with this
school that's what i mean it's like this
show has become the springboard for a
much bigger
it's like sorry i was so small with the
boba fett [ __ ] and that just gets like
[ __ ]
big as hell yeah yeah
with everything they're doing and uh
it's like how a soccer was there just to
pay this just
literally just to say what's up tomando
what's up to luke and then to leave i'm
gonna go to my other show and look for
general thrawn and then uh you know look
for sabine and as richard i'm gonna get
all that going
yeah just to remind you guys i got my
own series coming up
i'm here too
um but i like the i kind of like the
coldness i don't know if threatens
coldness but the intentional separation
the god the garden nature that luke has
towards danjarin
um that detached
it's just i feel like luke would just
have a little bit of a different
approach
and see i i feel i don't know he's got
so many very important personal
attachments
throughout the entire year in his life
yes
lady train's laying at one point here
right
in one of those
skywalker
he trains leo one point um
you know he obviously stays connected to
the family
so he keeps his attachments yeah
um so maybe that's a part of his journey
it's it's like the last time if like the
disney sequels never came out the live
action he was
he's just come off the death of anakin
skywalker you know like the guys at him
and he was celebrating with everyone so
the dude's like an emotional dude and uh
that was something that
obi wan as really explored heavily in
clone wars was
um with bogotan's sister oh my god what
is her name
yep
joe katana no no no
oh it's really bugging me that it's
blood that i'm throwing like it was such
a powerful like he
obviously had a romantic history with
her
and
you know like that's something he was
very much
like drew him a little bit further away
like there's a whole big speech he gives
at one point about like if you had asked
me to give up the jedi order i would
have
and
you know it's like that's something a
jedi always has to deal with so i
thought by this point luke might be a
little bit more towards the hair look
you could have some attachments
yeah and i get the point i i understand
the the thesis of the test but part of
me is like that would come in handy that
little bit of armor and also
you know
that's what it means
yeah so you you can never circumvent the
yeah the meaning behind it but part of
me is like just let them use it and then
just really focus on the jedi part of
the training because they have a debate
with each other about you know like he's
a he's a mandalorian family well maybe
he's a patent one
can't be both it was cooled in the
flashback of of grogu where you see the
66 yeah you see the clone troopers and
uh i'm so used to seeing them as cgi
prequels to see them brought to life
and like oh wow look at them they're an
actual costumer
yeah yeah for sure
and uh yeah that was intense i i i don't
know if gro i mean grog was already
interacted with boba in season two
and so i
i thought like if grogu had seen any
other the clone troopers faces he might
have been like ah you look like oh
you're all those people trying to kill
me
exactly oh no i don't want to help you
i wonder who those jedi were um someone
smarter than ourselves they'll have to
tell us in the comments but
they're a very specific jedi this was uh
this was awesome this was something else
um
holy [ __ ] i can't believe it um that was
and the music was beautiful and yes it
was
maloney killed it this time man he
really knocked it out of the park this
is such an oddly shaped show as a whole
but it's been very exciting the way it's
developed some of the best star wars
yeah yeah in recent memory yeah
that's all all it had to do i just had
to find their way to tv
all right
all right guys well look uh we gotta
start working on
actually putting this video together to
get to you guys so uh thanks for being
here and let's do a page
michael b
miguel
bien yo that's right man you are the
most dedicated person on our patreon
right now as we're shouting this out
you're probably editing your own
reaction to boba fett episode six and
hey man even though you are our direct
competition now i just wanted to let you
know
that uh you know we're gonna take that
very personally and we're out for you
specifically so any footage from the
show you use we're gonna claim you take
that as our own you know really make
sure that you know that this space is
our space all right you are a stranger
from the desert of youtube and you've
emerged
to threaten us and we can't have that
but uh
anyhow
we love you deep down beyond all that
and by the end of this season we will
reunite but for right now the game is
afoot
be well buddy
happy february that's good thank you
it's great
[Music]